you know the one very strange thing that
I've been thinking about on the 17th
anniversary of 9/11 as a parent of young
children and the thing that comes to
mind is that is that my kids will grow
up seeing 9/11 as this kind of event
from the ancient past right something
from something from which they are they
are detached kind of like how I saw when
I was a kid growing up I remember when I
when I learned about the Vietnam War or
the Cold War the JFK assassination when
I was a kid all those events were
relatively recent to me you know they
happen not long before my birth and my
parents remembered them and told me
about them but still it just felt like
something like something ancient and
that's how things that happen before you
were born I guess always feel at least
in modern society that's how they feel I
think maybe back back in the old days
people felt more connected to the past
even the past the things that happened
before they were born
but in this modern day and age when news
moves so quickly and I don't know we're
just so immersed in things that are
happening around us we're so immersed
kind of in in the present and we have
all this information coming at us all
the time
we're so aware of everything that's
happening in the world so it makes it
harder for us to feel connected to the
past and so that that's how it's kind of
strange that's the perspective that my
kids will have of 9/11 because it was an
event that was it was a probably the
defining event for my generation I
remember I was a freshman in high school
when 9/11 happened and everything
changed after that in fact it's very sad
I was also thinking about this the other
day
for me in my generation I was thinking
like what are the three what are the
three defining events for for my
generation people who are you know in
their late 20s early 30s right now and
I'm talking about national events not
personal events and so for me those
three events very easily very very
clearly would be there was first there
was Columbine which which happened when
I was in Middle School and we're sadly
so used to school shootings now but when
that happened it was it was
unprecedented at least it felt
unprecedented and it just changed
changed school it changed for from then
on out school just felt different and
there was this feeling of unease in
danger that you had in school that never
really went away after that and then
9/11 which like I said happened I think
it was a 9th or 10th grade would that
happen and then for me the last thing
being as I grew up in Maryland the last
defining event was the DC sniper which I
guess if you were in other parts of the
of the country so that was more just
like a news item but
around where I lived it was a very
terrifying time for a couple of for a
couple of weeks where you legitimately
thought that you might get shot when
you're walking to the bus stop or when
you come out of your house because
that's what was happening and so I was
thinking about how much fear anxiety
suspicion all of those things those
defining event events infused not just
into me personally but into everyone who
was growing up around that time so it's
kind of sad that I I think every
generation has tragic events that are
defining for them but I also think that
some generations have also great you
know tremendous of spectacular events
that are also defined I think about the
moon-landing you know for my
grandparents generation
but so far I don't know if we really
have anything like that at least for me
growing up all the all the big news
events the defining ones you throw the
Iraq war in there as well I mean there
were all terrible things right so in
that sense I'm glad that that had
happened long before my kids were born
because I don't really want something
like that to be a defining event for
them but in another ascent another sense
considering 9/11 was a defining national
event I don't want my kids to feel
completely disconnected from it either
though inevitably they will all right
now switching gears to a much much less
important story there's been a lot of
discussion about Serena Williams at the
US Open you know I'm sure you heard by
now Williams was docked by the umpire
for having a bit of a temper tantrum
smashing her racket verbally abusing the
umpire and so on and so on
she lost the match but her hysterics
successfully distracted from you know
the fact that she lost and overshadowed
the woman who beat her and which which
is very selfish on her part and later on
she claimed that she was the victim of a
sexist conspiracy so this is what she
said she's I've seen other men call
other Empire umpires several things I'm
here fighting for women's rights and for
women's equality and for all kinds of
stuff I want to go that's what I want to
focus I'm gonna go back to that but I'll
give you the whole quote she says for me
to say theif and because she called him
a thief I guess and for him to take a
game it made me feel like it was a
sexist remark he's never taken a game
from a man because they said thief she
also said I just feel like the fact that
I have to go through this is just an
example for the next person that has
emotions and that want to express
themselves they want to be a strong
woman they're going to be allowed to do
that because of today maybe it didn't
work out for me but it's going to work
out for the next person
now they're so very courageous whose
issues she's she's a pioneer setting the
stage for other women by having this
meltdown now there are a few things here
first of all
notice how she conflates her her temper
tantrum with strength and I think this
happens way too often in our society she
says that this makes her a strong woman
she's being a strong woman by losing her
cool and flipping up but you know a man
would would actually never get away with
that if a male athlete threw a fit at a
ref which that happens all the time
right i mean i don't watch tennis i do
watch football and you see football
players all the time you know getting
angry at the ref shouting coaches do it
okay so that does happen so serena
williams is not is not is not alone in
that but here's what you would never see
in a male athlete we'd never get away
with us after the game during the press
conference he couldn't say you know what
I was just being a strong man okay I was
being strong
you know that's that's that's what the I
was in the rest face a constant amount
I'm just being a strong man and you know
what I'm setting the stage I'm a pioneer
for other strong men so that they know
that they can express their emotions to
know a man would never he'd be laughed
out of the room if he said that
as well he should be
and as well Serena Williams should be
too because it is a laughable ridiculous
thing to say second second thing to take
from this there's this whole meme about
how women aren't allowed to get
emotional they aren't allowed to lose
their cool but men are you know that's
that's what we're hearing uh we're told
that men are never criticized for having
Tantrums themselves and in the tennis
world I I've heard a lot of people argue
that well John McEnroe used to be
verbally abusive all the time yeah and
he would flip out and he would and he
would scream and shot and everything and
and he never got in trouble for he was
never criticized for it I've actually
heard it's such an exceedingly stupid
argument that it's almost unbelievable
McEnroe was criticized all the time he
got in trouble all the time for his
temper I don't even follow tennis at all
but McEnroe was one of the only tennis
players I know precisely because of his
bad attitude he's one of the only ones I
know and the fact that he had a bad
attitude is the only thing I know about
him it was it was the thing that defined
his career for people like myself who
don't follow tennis so in fact it's it
notes it's Serena Williams who gets the
kid-glove treatment if she's the one
who's defended I don't think anyone ever
defended where were people are coming
out defending John McEnroe when he when
he acted inappropriately but did anyone
ever come out of claiming that he was a
hero fighting for rights and so forth
but anyone ever do no no one does that
for men when they when they act like
jerks that's the point okay I'm gonna
try to put this as as nicely as I can
but it's it's
when a man acts like a jerk nobody is
hesitant to call him a jerk
and that's it we just say well that
guy's acting like a jerk but if a woman
acts like a jerk well there are some
people who will call her a jerk but then
there's this whole other group of people
who come out and say and celebrate her
for it
so I don't think the jerky behavior of
men is really celebrated very often I
think it's almost always condemned but
no one has a problem condemning it
but with women
the the number of people who will
condemn jerky behavior is I think that
number is smaller
because there are those who will not
only tolerate it but will actually
outright defend it and justify it but
third and this is the biggest point I
wanted to focus on here
and just just using this as an example
okay because you have Serena Williams
and her claim that she's fighting for
women's rights
what was the exact quote she's fighting
for women's rights women's equality and
all that stuff or something and other
stuff too you know so we see here again
and I don't want to keep picking on
Serena Williams so I you know just using
that as this as a setup here to to get
to one of my my favorite things to
complain about witches which is how we
have taken this this concept of rights
and we have so cheapened it and turned
it into such a shallow and ridiculous
thing in American culture and that is
particularly the case with women's
rights so we see her again how women's
rights has become a meaningless phrase
in modern American society used by
feminists to reinforce this idea of this
fantasy of patriarchal oppression
and that's how it goes pretty much
anytime the left puts a qualifier in
front of the word rights
that's how it goes
you know that it's gonna be something
shallow and and petty and superficial
the moment they put a qualifier in front
of rights
but I think of all the fake rights
Crusades that are going on in America
right now none have become more absurd
or more frivolous than this idea of
women's rights
whenever someone in America says that
they're fighting for women's rights it
seems like it's always something dumb
like with you know Serena Williams says
she's fighting for women's rights by
cussing out the or shouting at the the
umpire and that tennis match I mean
that's it's just a perfect example of
what women's rights women's rights have
become in America that Serena Williams
is fighting for them by shouting at at a
tent umpire in a tennis match it just
seems like they're always when this idea
of women's rights comes up that the
person who's talking about they're
always referring to something silly like
that because there isn't any serious
women's rights battle left to be fought
in America women have all of the same
rights as men that fight is over and
thankfully women won women were fighting
legitimately for rights for a long time
they won they succeeded it's over now
great that that's good and so we should
just move on you know history should
just move on to other and more real
battles but but feminists have not
allowed that to happen
and now in fact you know we must say
that women not only have all the same
rights as men but that they even have
some rights that men don't have so if
there's any legal inequality going on in
America it is definitely going on in the
other direction
for instance women are the only ones who
have the legal right to kill children
okay now through abortion of course
that's not a right that I want or that I
think men should have or that I think
anyone should have but it is nonetheless
a a legal legal right a very
powerful legal right that only women
wield women are empowered to be judge
jury and executioner over human lives
men do not have that legal right
I mean you could point all you want to
there are a lot of violent men out there
who do terrible things and that's true
and feminists like to point that out the
in an effort to prove that women are you
know second-class citizens in America
are treated that way anyway but um in
those cases you know when a man does
something violently kill somebody it's
illegal he's gonna go to prison for that
and there are quite a lot of men in
prison for doing violent things
and you could say well we you know we
need we need to do a better job of
prosecuting violent man and I'll fine
I'll agree with you there
but the fact is men do not have the
right they don't have the legal right to
violently victimize anyone and if they
do violently victimize someone and they
can they don't go to jail for it it's
because they were able to successfully
argue that they never did that thing
but if it's found out that they did do
it they're gonna go to jail
trash that with something like abortion
where women have the legal right to kill
a human being a defenseless innocent
human being men do not have that one I
cannot think of any example of something
that men are allowed to do legally that
women are not allowed to do legally I
can't think of any example
I mean the only thing you had left was
you know you know like in the military
fighting on the frontlines out but all
that's changing now too so all of the if
there are any legal inequalities it
seems to go the other direction and we
could also look at the fact that women
get lighter sentences for the same
crimes in federal court there are fewer
women in prison there are fewer women
homeless there are a few and few er
women who are murder victims there are
fewer female dropouts in high school and
on and on and on so the idea that
women's rights must still be established
in America and that we need people like
Serena Williams to fight for them is
plainly absurd now here's the thing I'm
not saying that men's rights need to be
established either my point is we need
to stop qualifying rights
so stop talking about women's rights
don't talk about men's rights because
that's that's just as bad when you've
got some menu but now you've got the
men's rights activist on the other side
who are trying to respond to the
feminists and so they're being essential
they're becoming the antithesis of
feminists they're becoming the no
feminists for the other side which is a
which is no good either
because that entire way of looking at
things is wrong and flawed we need to
stop trying to divide people up into
groups and give them their own special
rights because the whole idea is that
all people are supposed to have the same
rights
that's human rights that's the concept
here we should we don't we shouldn't be
dividing it down and and all that you
know and and and giving it up and
separating and distinguishing
now everyone has the same rights that's
the idea that our founding father said
now there was a there was a glaring
oversight for the founding fathers
because they said that all people have
the same rights and people are created
equal except they excluded racial
minorities and women from that from that
group so
it was very necessary for us to go back
and correct that and make sure that we
include racial minorities and women in
that group
that's been done thankful
and so that's that's it that's all we
should do as far as that goes as far as
rights go that's it
what we needed to do was cook was
correct the mistakes of the past and
make sure that everyone in America
really does have equal legal rights and
once that was done as far as rights go
that should be the end of the discussion
and now you just let people go and live
with that freedom
and and the the you know how they choose
to use those freedoms and the outcome of
those use of them using those freedoms
that's an entirely different discussion
and that's not going to be the same it's
not going to be equal
but as long as as long as everyone is
allowed to do legally the same sorts of
things and legally they have the same
opportunities open to them then then we
could say that the fight for rights is
over
now there are so there are other human
rights fights in America that still need
to be had the one that I referenced
earlier for instance there is still a
group of human beings who are
categorically excluded from the idea of
human rights and those would be unborn
children so that's a fight that still
needs to be had we still are we still we
still after after all this time still
have not reached a point where everyone
in America is included under the concept
of human rights
which is a very you know it's very sad
when you think about it
that we had you know we had this the the
founding of America and supposedly
everyone had equal rights but of course
racial minorities and women were
excluded and then there was this battle
for over a century you know century and
a half to get to make sure everyone
really was included and so we had just
kind of established that and then almost
immediately you have roe v-- wade and
now we're excluding a whole other group
of people
like we almost got to the point where we
had it right and everyone really had
equal rights and then we ruined it so
that's still a
a fight that needs to be had
now
I think so you know you have the concept
of Rights which again that's just as
long as we all have the same legal
opportunities and nobody is legally
excluded
from you know doing certain things or
being treated a certain way then you
have rights
um so there's no reason to talk about
women's rights unless we're talking
about unborn females whoo-hoo you know
across the world anyway are
disproportionately affected by abortion
you have sex selective abortion
everything else everything else but
aside from that we could put the rights
discussion to the side all but we still
could have a discussion and should have
a discussion about other about ways that
our culture particularly degrades women
now that isn't that our culture removes
rights from them
these are not women's rights issues but
they are human issues
there are issues that seem to especially
impact females
you know for example you have the porn
industry pornography which primarily
trades in the debasement and
objectification of women and children
for another example you have the fact
that femininity in our culture is
constantly cheapened by this concept of
transgenderism who insists that they can
become women by you know mutilate the
mutilating themselves or putting on a
dress or something like that so again
the idea of womanhood has been cheapened
and objectified and appropriated by men
so that's an issue of women being
degraded and - based in our culture and
then for another example to go back to
what another time women are victimized
by the abortion industry
and not just because girls are often
targeted for sex selective abortion but
because women are lied to and taken
advantage of and told to convinced
coerced into denying the gift of
motherhood rejecting the the life in
their womb and embracing this life of
regret and emptiness and guilt
so pornography transgenderism abortion
these are very real enemies of women in
our culture
because they defile women they objectify
they cheapen they degrade they kill but
you'll notice that feminists with very
rare exceptions when they talk about
women's rights they're not referring to
any of those things
they usually support all of those things
those are the real battlefields
the real battles that need to be fought
they said you know they're on the wrong
side of those where women are actually
being victimized there they're usually
in favor of all that
but then they're gonna go and rally
behind Serena Williams because you know
because she got in trouble with an
umpire in tennis so pretty much tells
you everything you need to know about
the state of feminism in in modern
America all right I'm gonna leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
and remember remember to say a prayer
for our country on this anniversary of
9/11 Godspeed